Hausa go and rest mine is feared fat
welcome to baking simulator there's a
complete ripoff of surgeon simulator but
hey let's play it left shift this a lot
of [ __ ] man what a beautiful day oh my
god what happened to my pants
how much what okay here's what you add
ingredients to bowl but they're bowling
hamon num am I why don't I just eat my
hands they look delicious
let's add the eggs I can only move one
hand at a time yeah this is my jam this
is literally my jam where is my jam
seriously I looking for my jam here I'm
trying to make a cake all right I got
this head and I am ready to get some
eggs no job like oh my [ __ ] edit that
outfits
there we go done what else do you want
from me you [ __ ] hate us I don't
understand this game let's try that
again
nailed that just go in good job let's
get out McQueen what the [ __ ] why am I
so scared X I don't know why is I don't
expect them to [ __ ] explode and [ __ ]
god dammit no this is so [ __ ] hard
are you cereal in my bag I'm even have
milk in this house
oh let's see maybe my right hand is more
gentle
oh my fat with that hat huh Oh got your
[ __ ] ah Wow how do I Wow
goddamnit yes got you now what do I do
but let's not make the bowl crack all
right down no oh God oh how is that even
possible
I must have few super demonstrate my
Superman is that it tried so hard to
lose it uh a knee woo in the egg alright
let's just drop it like it's hot which
I'm not capable up the egg is in now
let's add up careful careful
give her all right down yeah no no why
what are you doing oh yes all right
let's flower that [ __ ] alright here we
go oh god oh god oh god yes that looks
like an adequate amount of flour Oh 102
grams that's what we needed perfect we
need another egg which is very
concerning do I have the egg nein
what are you doing there what are you
doin a thank God the sill hope Russ
there's still hope for our cake let it
go let it go man yeah oh my god I got a
hi-fi myself I can time to retire I'm
too stupid let's do this again I got a
[ __ ] cake this bake man but cake make
whatever okay don't don't nail that what
is wrong with you do you hate the bakes
cakes I've got too much flour oh you can
never have too much flour I love how all
the eggs fell out but it still counts
all right let's butter up that [ __ ] I
got it no how do you grab butter
Oh God butter don't escape don't escape
I'm your friend butter I'm your friend
baddest ahh don't sip through my fingers
butter oh yeah it's so slimy oh you
little slimy little [ __ ] okay I got it
with my thumb all right let it go let it
go man let go of the butter leg up thank
you what else we need sugar
all right last ingredient don't [ __ ]
this up it's okay oh I got it I got you
buddy I got your sugar whatever go sugar
that [ __ ] what are you doing
this is not how you what did i do what
did i do to deserve this
god damn it God you have it it's not
fair life is out there meeting jab luck
you gonna fit Kaka I hate this game with
a passion man there we go two eggs like
a boss
two eggs like a bounce two eggs like a
palace - egg - egg sack about two eggs
two eggs like a bells
Mouse two eggs like a mouse mouse two
eggs like a miles miles miles girl
two eggs like a bounce two eggs like a
bounce flour you [ __ ] you mother
double fisting eggs double wrap Oh
double spin what's up double flour and
my ass don't put flowers in my aunt
please series in my hand what is that
Hey ah doing jab Lacock feet kooky ask a
fun okay all right you know what is it
go again it's going in let's make sure
we make a precise image of the flower
yes that is pretty precise drop it don't
dance ingredients don't dance the bowl
is moving make the poles stop moving
please
okay okay I'm fine
I'll find it I'm fine I'm [ __ ] fine
bake a cake they said it would be fun
they said cakes a tasty they said what
is this shape I will cook you all in the
oven and you will taste delicious so
just don't make it doubled egg-drop
thank you very much
flower power well thought when flour
doesn't want to flour what do you do I
don't want to fail now we came so far
man [ __ ] hell that's all you got okay
that's I don't even care anymore let's
just put this [ __ ] in the oven
shut up oven no one likes you
yes Oh
I still think there's a chance of this
cake being delicious and I will not let
that cake chance deliciousness be for
granted
hey I'm gonna make this cake it's the
last thing I'll ever [ __ ] do I'm
gonna make this cake in your ass if I
have to
preferably not because that's [ __ ]
nasty you [ __ ] egg racist
[ __ ] come on it's only this
[ __ ] sugar piece of [ __ ] what the
hell easy easy we have it we have the
cake thank you thank you I don't hate
you I don't hate you so don't make me
hate you okay ah then oven oven I would
please use the Falls to open the oven
place uh-huh yes uh-huh
so fare is so bad I would I didn't even
let go of the buttons it just let go of
itself a cake just didn't wanna
left-right press I have another cake
don't fret
yes all right we got it we got this for
us
just easy easy lemon [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] Abbess of this hellhole of a
mother why am I not walking straight
what is this is it that hard he can't
focus all right why does he drop it why
why did he do that huh I got some quad
eggs for eggs coz I don't give a [ __ ] an
inappropriate amount of sugar cuz I
don't give a [ __ ] dancing ass but it's
cuz I don't give us a perfect amount of
flour cuz I don't give us I will put you
on the lower bar cuz apparently they
didn't say in the instructions but if
you drop your damn cake if you shut up
shut up shut your [ __ ] mouth
alright alright and you go and you go
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I will [ __ ] you so
[ __ ] hard let go oh my god
yeah
it's not even a cake it's not even a
cake the cake
it's a lie